كثير من الموتى قليل من الاحياء تلك هي
المعادله الان في المناطق المنكوبه بعد
مضي اسبوع على كارثه الزلزال في شمال غربي
سوريا تدخل مهمه فرق الانقاذ مرحله
الاحباط والياس فهي الان تكاد تنحصر في
انتشال الجثث ورفع الانقاض وحده تنسيق
الدعم التي تتولى استلام المساعدات
وتوزيعها في تلك المناطق اكدت ان عدد
القتلى تخطى اربعه الاف بينما يقترب عدد
الجرح والمصابين من ثمانيه الاف وهي حصيله
غير نهائيه حيثما يزال مئات الاشخاص
عالقين تحت الانقاض فيما لا يقل عن 90
مبنى منهارا
عوامل كثيره جعلت الكارثه هناك بهذا السوء
منها عدم وصول اي فرق اغاثه خارجيه او
معدات حفر في الوقت المناسب ولا حتى بعد
فوات الاوان كما ان الزلزال ضرب اكثر من
100 موقع يضم كل منها مباني ومنازل بكثافه
سكانيه متفاوته فضلا عن ان المنطقه التي
يتكدس فيها مئات الاف النازحين الفارينه
من هجمات النظام السوري كانت اصلا في ظروف
سيئه قبل الزلزال
قائمه الاحتياجات طويله وتتصدرها طلبات
عاجله لاكثر من مئه فرقه انقاذ لدعم فرق
الدفاع المدني المحلي التي يعمل فيها
حاليا اقل من الف متطوع كما تشمل
الاحتياجات العاجله اكثر من 400 اليه
مختلفه المهام والوظائف من شاحنات لنقل
الركام واليات للحفر والنبش وجرافات
واليات اخرى اما متطلبات السكان بمن فيهم
الناجون والمصابون والذين باتوا بلا ماوى
فتبدو اكثر استعجالا وفق نداء وحده تنسيق
الدعم يحتاجون اكثر من 100 الف وجبه طعام
يوميا ونحو 160 الف قطعه من الاغطيه
والمفارش فضلا عن اكثر من سته ملايين لتر
من وقود التدفئه في مناخ شتوي بالغ القسوه